Speaker 1: As predicted by anyone who has been
following the way Donald Trump behaves for the
last many years upon the verdict of 17 guilty
counts for Donald Trump's organization in this
massive fraud case out of the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office, Donald Trump explodes. First
and foremost, the message posted to Twitter
by Donald Trump's Soviet style PR person,
Liz Harrington and Trump in all caps,
calling it the Manhattan Witch Hunt,
putting out the following statement. And I it's
always physically demanding to read these things,
quote, disappointed with the verdict in Manhattan,
but will appeal after looking at millions of
pages of documents over many years, much to the
detriment of record setting murder and other forms
of violent crime that are taking place in New York
City. Those are unrelated things. The government,
Capital G, was able to get an employee
to, quote, plea. Why his plea in quotes,
I don't know. That's quite literally what happened
in order for a very reduced sentence. This case
was about Allen Weisselberg committing tax
fraud on his personal tax returns, etc.
with he and every witness repeatedly testifying
that President Trump and the Trump family with
a capital F knew nothing about his actions, which
he admits were done solely for his own benefit and
with no benefit to the two companies. Why would
Capital C corporations which knew nothing about
Weisselberg's personal tax returns be prosecuted
for that person's conduct? There was reliance
by us on a then highly respected and expensive
accounting firm and law firm to do this work. The
accounting firm also did his personal returns,
which we are not even allowed to legally view.
This case is unprecedented and involve no monetary
gain to these two capital C corporations. It is
the continuing continuation of the Capitol
greatest political witch hunt in the capital
H history of our capital c country. New York City
is a hard place to be. Quote Trump as businesses
and people flee our once capital g. Great Capital
C city. Uh, none of that making a lot of sense.
And the fear, of course, in Trump is that all of
this stuff is getting closer and closer. Trump
not implicated directly here in a legal sense. But
of course, Trump knows everything that goes on in
his businesses and 17 guilty verdicts get against
Trump is understandably and expectedly triggering
to the failed former president. And this was
not the only bad news for Donald Trump yesterday
because we learned that the Trump riot committee
will indeed be making criminal referrals.